Parliament will have his final play on a  controversial EU Canada trade deals with  Canadian Premier Justin Trudeau  travelling to Strasbourg for the  occasion the deal has sparked eu-wide  protest and had yet to win the backing  of national young makers rules to stop  returning jihadist fighters and lone  wolves like the girl in Christmas market  attacker will be adopted alongside  mandatory EU border checks part of  ongoing efforts to prevent a repeat of  the power of aggressive attack any PS  have big ideas for the EU future ahead  of its 60th anniversary they want to  improve how crises are handled for  instance by creating a special budget  for the eurozone Heavy Industries should  get fewer carbon credits to help curb  pollution under the blocks emissions  trading system MEP say but they still  have to convince the new government